in this course you'll learn to use git
which is a version control system and
github a code sharing and collaboration
platform you'll need to use a UNIX tile
command line so if you haven't used that
before then check out one of the
tutorials in the instructors notes
you'll also be looking at some code in
this course so experience reading and
writing code will be useful but it
doesn't matter which particular
programming languages you know to give
you a better sense of what you'll learn
if you stick with us through this course
here's the rough breakdown we'll have 3
lessons in this first lesson we'll focus
on how version control can be useful and
what different forms it might take
you'll also install git and start using
it to explore some existing code then in
lesson 2 you'll learn more about git and
start using it on your own
finally in lesson 3 you get some
practice sharing code and collaborating
with others using github